thank you very much for being on the
program and we're here on the local
election campaign trail with you so what
does the good night look like then for
labor next week well we're running a
very positive campaign we've got a
really good set of candidates
um and we're hoping to make progress and
I'm humble about this I know we've got
to earn every vote but we do want to
make progress
the cycle is the cycle four-year cycle
from May 2019 as you know so that means
it's quite hard for us because in May
2019 if you cast your mind back we had
Theresa May as prime minister and the
local election results for the Tory
party back in 2019 were the second worst
in their history and Theresa May had to
go out after those elections and
apologized for candidates because the
results were so appalling so I think for
the conservative party the Baseline is
on the floor and they should be making
gains and if they don't if they can't
make games on that awful set of results
then I think there are serious questions
as to whether Rishi sunak is going
backwards in fact in terms of their
electoral prospects so it's a it's a
difficult cycle because you know of that
Baseline but I think really the question
will be why aren't the tourists making
pretty significant gains so you're
seriously saying the conservatives
should be making significant gains right
well in 2019 that was their second worst
set of results ever and Theresa May I
mean as I say apologize to Canada I
think three weeks later she was
challenged for the leadership resigned
and that was it was effectively those
results I mean we should be expecting a
thousand losses well if they are I find
that astonishing if they're saying that
uh they're going to go below their
second worst set of results in these
elections then
um they truly are going backwards but
that I think is just expectation
Management on their part they ought to
be made making games significant gains
the base law Baseline for them is on the
floor and so this will raise questions
about whether they're going backwards in
fact you have been enjoying a pretty
comfortable lead in the polls for a
while now
a little bit though isn't it are you
worried about the trajectory well I've
set my stall out in 2020 when I became
leader of the labor party picked us up
from the worst general election results
since 1935 and said we must take
ourselves from there into a labor
government so looking at that and the
question I ask myself is are we making
Pro progress on that trajectory and then
the art studies yes we've changed the
party but the polls are narrowing so
that's my question I guess are you still
making progress yes I mean the polls
that we saw in the Autumn of last year
in the middle of the mini budget were
never going to last I think everybody
accepted that but the real question is
are we making progress from that
terrible result in 2019 towards the next
general election and I'm pleased in the
sense that the question the challenge I
get now is not the challenge I got when
I took over which is it's impossible so
many people shook me by the hand when I
became leader labor party said good luck
here but you'll never turn it around in
a five-year Parliament it's not possible
for labor to go from that to win the
challenge now is why aren't you further
ahead well that shows we've made
progress we've changed the party I'll
analyze these results as I always do
against the underlying constituencies as
we head into the general election of
2024 in all probability okay and I want
to talk to you about a few of the kind
of big issues now um nurses strikes a
huge issue for so many people lots of
anxiety and they're striking without
exemptions for emergency care so no a e
maternity Cancer Care are they wrong to
do that I don't want these strikes to go
ahead I don't think anybody does I don't
think the nurses do but I do think the
government has made a complete mess of
the negotiation the question is should
nurses be striking without exemptions
for emergency care well I don't want to
see the strikes go ahead so they're
wrong to do that I don't want to see the
strikes go ahead but the way to avoid
about the exemptions that's what I'm
asking about specifically the way to
avoid strikes is to get in the room with
the nurses and to resolve these issues
now if you remember Before Christmas the
RCN said to the government if you get
into the room with us and negotiate
about pay we won't go on strike at all
but they happen they've got an offer
that they put to the members the
government then sat it out for week
after week after week and they caused
the situation now where we're in a real
mess and the government needs to learn
that lesson get in the room negotiate
this compromise and get on with it and
you know nobody but nobody wants to
strikes in nursing in hospitals in
Railway or anywhere else I can quite
understand uh the pressures bearing down
on nurses and doctors and those who work
on the railways because wages have been
stagnant for over a decade living
standards haven't gone up and bills have
gone up everywhere because there's an
underlying structural problem here which
is that we haven't grown the economy the
economy has had no effective growth for
13 years that is an utter failure of
this government that is the heart of
these strikes cost of living crisis of
course we've had you train of course
we've had covered but our country is
faring worse than other countries and
there's a reason for that and it's the
13 years of failure I'm still slightly
unclear if I'm honest about whether or
not you think it is acceptable for
nurses to strike without exemptions
um at pmqs last week you said either the
Prime Minister doesn't use the same
Public Services as the rest of us or he
simply can't see the damage what do you
mean that he doesn't use the same Public
Services as the rest of us I think if
the prime minister or other Tories
saw firsthand
the way our NHS is operating they would
better understand just how damaged it is
what do you mean by that though I'm just
trying are you basically saying he's too
wealthy to use public services in the
same way as others is that what you're
trying to say I'm saying it's out of
touch that he doesn't know what's
happening in the everyday lives of very
many millions you're saying he doesn't
use the same Public Services what do you
mean well I mean he's out of touch talk
to anybody who's trying to get an
appointment with a GP that eight o'clock
call they know how hard it is they know
the Health Service is broken anybody in
a waiting list anybody actually going
into a e my wife works in the NHS this
is a constant discussion I say to her
the NHS is on its knees she says to me
no it's not it's on its face and that is
the result of 13 years of neglect and
um when I look at what's happened to our
NHS it breaks my heart that it's been
allowed to get into this state which is
why we've set out that one of our
missions if we do have the privilege of
winning the next election will be to you
know build an NHS fit for the future
we've got to fix the NHS and you know
it's the same with the cost of living
crisis the Prime Minister sort of smiles
his way through the cost of living
crisis without understanding the real
impact I was in Ripley and near Derby
this morning talking to people in the
local co-op in the cafe and it's the
same story across all of these local
lectures people saying to me I go around
the supermarket I pick things up and
then I put them back down again I turn
my heating on for a short period in the
morning but not otherwise because even
though it's cold I can't afford to pay
the bills pensioners who feel that you
know they've put in all their lives but
now when they want just a bit of comfort
they can't make ends meet I don't think
I don't think the Prime Minister
understands I don't think I mean this
morning people saying to me I don't
think he understands what I'm actually
the way my life is and I think that's a
real problem because a question in
politics is who have you got in your
mind's eye when you make your decisions
and I've got in mind mines either people
I was talking to this morning I think
he's got in his Mind's Eye the richest
one percent because it's that richest
one percent that he gave a tax break too
I'm Keen to talk a bit more about
Richard Cena later but while we're
talking about public services you've got
an announcement on house building are
you going to bring back mandatory house
building targets yes and I'll tell you
for why because having your own house
the it is hugely important for security
so I mean I know this when I was growing
up my dad was a tool maker my mum was a
nurse we didn't have a lot of money but
we had our own house and that's a sense
of security and that's why people dream
aspire to have their own house home
ownership and that dream has been killed
by the Prime Minister because he took
down the targets he himself has admitted
that he did it because he was giving in
to his own members that shows a
fundamental weakness and it's he who
accepts he gave into them and he's
killed that dream of home ownership at
the same time though these targets were
in place until late last year there
weren't enough houses been built then
either were there if you really want to
transform the housing market you have to
take on overall local contents right are
you prepared to take on the nimbies yes
so we need to get the target back
to show strength and build out of the
damage that the Prime Minister has
inflicted on the country but we also
need I think to take on the planning
laws make sure that local authorities
have greater power to decide whether
housing will be in their patch and to
ensure that we have the vehicles for
delivery you know Housing and
Development corporations that are
actually a vehicle to delivery so yes we
would have the ambition to do that but
at the moment I can't emphasize enough
this is I was up in Preston yesterday
with barretts and they were saying the
market for first-time buyers has just
gone through the roof it's Fallen away
as a joint result of the Kamikaze mini
budget which threat mortgages and
mortgage deals through the roof so it's
now unaffordable and the taking down of
targets which means less housing less
affordable housing so people are Out Of
Reach and they are then forced to
continue in high rent you know rental
accommodation Which is far too high and
you know generation rent rent in a sense
is being held in a headlock by this
government
um
in to use this program I try and kind of
look forward but I just want to go back
to something if I may because I think
it's quite important and if I'm being
honest I don't feel like you've been
properly putting questions about it so
at the beginning of April labor
published an attack at which had a
picture of Rishi sunak and it said do
you think adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children should go to prison
which she seen that doesn't now you've
since said that you stand by every word
of that right so do you care starmer
believe that rishis United thinks that
pedophile should not go to jail is that
what you're saying the figures speak for
themselves no I'm not talking about the
figures because we're talking about what
it says here in the ad do you think
adults convicting convicted of sexually
assaulting children should go to
prisoner doesn't yeah is that what you
think
I think if he did think they should go
to prisoner do something about it so you
don't think he thinks Peter Paul should
go to prison is that what you're
seriously saying I stand by the advert
is that so that's what the advert says
you're is that what you're seriously
saying yes I think that as prime
minister you take responsibility for
what happens in your criminal justice
system he is not taking responsibility
for it and this idea that somehow you
can ship in a new prime minister we've
had five of them now in the last 13
years and that somehow he doesn't bear
responsibility they have broken our
criminal justice system so it is
unforgivable
do you take personal responsibility then
for every child abuser who escaped
prison while were you a director of
public prosecutions I took full
responsibility for every decision of the
crown prosecution
responsibility is that what you're
saying I'll tell you how that worked
when I was director of public
prosecutions it meant that when we
succeeded in some very important
prosecutions as we did there was a an
attempt to bring down seven planes
across the Atlantic at the same time a
massive terrorist operation we
prosecuted that successfully got a
awards for that and I took the credit
for that on behalf of the organization
where we got it wrong I carried the can
and what that meant to me carrying the
can was identifying what the problem was
and what we needed to fix it so when I
carried the can I looked at the problem
I analyzed what had gone wrong rolled up
my sleeves and fixed it from the
government you're accepting they would
have a completely different system
you're accepting then that things went
wrong under your watch right and I'm not
going to get into what they were because
I don't want to engage in it if I'm
being completely honest
um but that doesn't mean that you don't
think that rapists should go to jail
does it it means that you just take a
responsibility for it that's what you're
saying in this ad well you know the
question in a sense has to be put to the
Prime Minister which is if he contests
this why is he not doing something about
it and fixing the situation but which is
the approach I took you take the
plaudits when the organization does very
well which the crown prosecution service
did a lot under my watch but if
something does go wrong you analyze
what's the problem and you fix it
under the conservatives four thousand
five hundred adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children under 16
serve no prison time now that's figures
from the last 13 years of conservative
government I mean CNN wasn't even an MP
for five of those let alone having any
responsibility for the justice system
well this idea that 13 years of
doesn't think pedophile should go to
jail that's what's saying we've had 13
years of failure
um we've had 13 years in which we've had
five prime ministers the idea that you
can just slot in a new prime minister
and suddenly the Slate is wipe clear
they have no responsible he is taking
that political party into the next
general election and his his message
will be to the country notwithstanding
the failure now 13 years probably 14 by
the time we get to the next general
election give me and us another five
years that is the biggest risk to our
country five more years of this failure
and one of the things we're talking
about this morning with people in the
court was do you feel any better off is
anything working better after 13 years
the risk in this country is not changed
to a labor party that will clear up the
mess and take us forward the risk is
carrying on with five more years of this
failure we know far-right groups have
weaponized the sexual abuse abuse
committed by Asian grooming gangs right
a very small minority of Asians now your
attacker had accuses the first ever
British Asian prime minister of not
thinking child sex abusers to go to
prison is it racist no there's a huge
um you know under analysis of the
figures here and I looked at this when I
was director of public prosecutions the
vast majority of child sexual offenses
are not uh by uh people of Asian origin
or anything else absolutely so it's not
a racist effect then no it's not of
course it's not okay okay
um now I'm Keen to move on to talk about
other things as well Richard Sharp has
resigned as the chairman of the uh BBC
this crisis in part caused because some
people would feel that the government is
effectively trying to get an ally into
that job do you think that that power to
appoint people to these kind of roles
should be taken out of government hands
yes I think it'd be far better if it was
an independent process and what you've
got is yet another example of contact
with the with those at the top of the
Tory party leading to this sort of
outcome this resignation is only the
latest of a series of issues like this
where there's been that contamination at
the top of the Tory party so yes we need
to do something about it it has done
damage to the BBC
to its impartiality well it's certainly
done damage the reputation of the BBC so
we would have an independent process
look at what that process looks like to
ensure that those sorts of mistakes
can't be those sorts of associations
wouldn't be possible under a labor
government but we also need to clean up
politics because you know we've had
issue after issue where there's sleaze
there's suggestions of contracts being
awarded to people who know each other in
the conservative party we've got to end
that sort of politics and I'm interested
as well in your you said that it's done
damage the reputation of the BBC I'm
interested in your wider view of the UK
media as well and you obviously um
brought convictions towards journalists
of phone hacking and also payments
public officials when you director of
public prosecutions would you like to
see a levison too well there are
outstanding issues there although a lot
of time has passed since levison won
um so you know I think there are still
issues but you know let me be clear I'm
setting out the priorities of the next
Labor government in the missions that
I'm setting out and at the moment my
absolute focus is on those five missions
which is you know our economy the
fastest sustained growth in the G7
making sure that we can power towards
clean energy by 2030 Safe Streets better
opportunities for everybody and so those
those missions are what drives me
forward so you know are there still
issues yes there are but I'll be clear
we will be a priorities-led government
with an absolute focus on the missions
that I've set out so at the minute not a
priority well the the first priority is
going to have to be growing the economy
the sink the highest sustained growth in
the G7 is what we want to go for and
that is important because you know we
often have arguments about tax and spend
the best way to have better public
services to have our businesses thriving
is to grow our economy and that's will
be the single focus of an incoming labor
government now just uh wrapping up
you're an Arsenal fan yes what's more
likely Arsenal we're in the Premier
League or you win in the election oh us
winning the election I think yeah I
haven't gone through what we went
through in the game with Man City the
other night then I'm afraid I think for
this year it's over for Arsenal but it's
a brilliant squad for the future so
you're not going to chat with a big lead
then well look you know there's a lesson
there because at the beginning of every
season people confidently predict who's
going to win the league in the end it
comes to April before it really is
decided there's a lesson in there for
politics we've got to fight all the way
into the next election got a fight like
we're Five Points behind and we've got
to make our positive case for the
electorate thank you very much thank you